There’s no doubt that the SCP Foundation
has come across some dangerous anomalies over
the years.
If you had to guess, what would you say is
the most dangerous SCP they have in containment?
A lot of people might immediately think of
SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile, and
perhaps they’d might be right.
After all, we’re talking about a gigantic
lizard that can regenerate almost all forms
of damage, and harbors a burning hatred for
any and all other forms of life.
Then there’s the various eldritch entities
the Foundation has come into contact with,
beings that could easily rewrite all of reality
out of pure anger, or just to torment us for
their own amusement.
But the most dangerous SCP might well be something
completely unassuming.
Instead of a zombie producing plague doctor,
or an actual plague of flesh eating zombies
, imagine if there was just a man.
One seemingly ordinary human man, nothing
about him that looks unusual, no memetic or
anomalous superpower.
And yet, one look at him tells you he’s
the most dangerous man you’ve ever seen,
someone who should be locked up forever for
all the horrible things he’s done.
Welcome to the story of Fraisure Melbrook,
the Most Dangerous Person, also known as SCP-3017.
To anyone that knew him, Fraisure was just
an ordinary man.
Although, at twenty five years of age, he
had not exactly lived a charmed life.
People would look at him and could almost
tell there was something unsavory about Fraisure’s
character.
It was as if one glance could somehow tell
you that he was trouble.
It was this unshakable feeling that he gave
people that led to Fraisure Melbrook being
arrested.
And arrested.
And arrested some more.
Over the course of his adult life, he was
placed under arrest a total of twenty-three
times.
Fraisure was suspected to have committed a
number of different crimes, ranging from robbery
and assault, all the way up to accusations
of murder.
Interestingly, he was never formally indicted
for any of his alleged crimes, meaning he
was only ever arrested and held as a suspect.
But never once was he confirmed to have been
guilty.
There was never any evidence, nothing to prove
beyond reasonable doubt that Fraisure was,
in fact, a criminal.
Instead, every arrest boiled down to the way
he made people in his presence feel.
Unfortunately, even though he was never proven
to be guilty, or even capable of committing
the crimes he was accused of, Fraisure Melbrook’s
multiple arrests garnered him a notable criminal
record, and soon drew the attention of the
SCP Foundation.
When he was transferred into Foundation containment
and designated as SCP-3017, it was believed
that Fraisure had some form of connection
to a number of Groups of Interest.
These are various organizations that the Foundation
monitors, viewing them as causes for concern
and sometimes outright threats.
This list includes The Church of The Broken
God; a cult of religious zealots that worship
an entity that combines a number of SCPs.
As well as the Global Occult Coalition, a
gung-ho organization policing the paranormal
that shares an uneasy history with the Foundation.
However, no member of staff could explain
exactly why they thought Fraisure Melbrook
had any connection to these groups, there
was no evidence that he was, but still, they
had a hunch.
And so, testing began.
Hours upon hours of rigorous interviews and
experimentation, trying to understand what
it was that made people want to keep this
seemingly ordinary man locked up.
After extensive research was conducted by
Foundation personnel, they were able to determine
why SCP-3017 had been arrested so many times
before, and what had drawn the Foundation
to him in the first place.
Fraisure Melbrook was suffering from a cognitohazard.
This was a condition that did not so much
have a direct, adverse effect on him, but
rather influenced those around him.
Anyone that stood close enough to SCP-3017,
or made an attempt to engage him directly
in conversation, even those that just looked
at him, all reacted the same way.
Fraisure gave people the overwhelming belief
that he needed to be placed in custody, even
if he’d not said or done anything to give
them a reason to.
Anyone that looked at, spoke to, or even stood
near him became spontaneously aware that SCP-3017
was some sort of dangerous criminal.
The cognitohazard didn’t give people knowledge
of his exact crimes, it more just made them
believe that Fraisure had a violent disposition
and that he needed to be locked away.
Any person staying within the vicinity of
SCP-3017 for an hour or longer would experience
further effects of Fraisure’s cognitohazard.
Beyond just knowing there was something untowards
about him, those who spent extended time around
SCP-3017 would actively try to restrain him,
and then after an hour they would exhibit
violent behavior towards him.
They would start obsessively trying to ensure
he was incarcerated, almost like the thought
of him being free was so horrifying that they
couldn’t help but try to arrest him themselves.
Luckily, these effects of longer exposure
to Fraisure were not permanent and often the
subjects’ tendencies to try and restrain
him could be cured through amnestics.
The effects of Fraisure Melbrook’s cognitohazardous
condition seemed to change relative to the
amount of time he remained incarcerated.
After continuous exposure to SCP-3017, the
effects of his cognitohazard would appear
to fade, meaning that those who had previously
been compelled to incarcerate him would later
become indifferent, or even release him freely.
This caused a problem for the Foundation and
raised a very important question: How do you
contain someone that you later feel the urge
to set free?
The answer was designated SCP-3017-1, a list
of individuals with a connection to Fraisure
Melbrook, all of whom had seemingly become
immune to the outward effects of his condition.
Not one of these people could be convinced
that Fraisure was the violent criminal that
everyone else saw.
Among the list of names were Frasure’s parents
Vivian and Beck, along with his siblings,
grandmother, former classmates, and romantic
partners, and his fiancé Nadia.
But, you might be wondering, how did the SCP
Foundation use nothing more than a list of
names to keep SCP-3017 caged?
By threatening them, of course.
Researchers who interviewed Fraisure found
that they could greatly decrease the secondary
effect of his condition, making them far less
compelled to free him.
All it took was for them to tell Fraisure
that his family, friends, fiancé would be
captured, tortured, or even killed if he tried
to escape containment.
According to the Foundation, this didn’t
stop Fraisure from trying to escape though.
His file states that he actively made several
attempts to breach containment, all of which
failed.
The truth, however, was that just about any
move that Fraisure made was misinterpreted
as an attempted escape.
In one instance, while just trying to use
the bathroom, SCP-3017 was tackled and restrained
by a Foundation guard.
You see, Fraisure knew that just like with
his previous arrests, he’d done nothing
to deserve being locked up and interrogated
by the SCP Foundation.
But, to the eyes of everyone around him, he
was a dangerous threat.
The researchers and guards treated him like
a monster, because as far as they saw, he
was one.
By manipulating information about the current
health of his loved ones, like telling him
his grandmother had developed lung cancer,
the Foundation kept Fraisure under lock and
key.
Hearing threats against his friends and family,
or bad news about their current state quickly
put an end to SCP-3017’s attempts at escape.
Even though he was frustrated with the Foundation,
he was without hope, and had little choice
in the matter.
So, Fraisure did his best to comply with his
captors and offer the SCP Foundation information
on Groups of Interest he thought they wanted
to hear, even though he had no affiliation
with any of them.
By bringing Fraisure’s fiancé, Nadia, into
containment and showing him a live video feed
of her, Foundation researcher Doctor Kiran
hoped to coax a wealth of valuable information
out of SCP-3017.
Afraid for his partner’s life, Fraisure
did his best to answer their questions, and
Nadia was later freed and given amnestics
to forget the incident.
But Foundation Researcher Rylan was quick
to realize that the information Doctor Kiran
had extracted from SCP-3017 didn’t seem
to add up.
Fraisure, of course, had no knowledge about
any Groups of Interest, and had to improvise
to protect his fiancé.
Researcher Rylan picked up on this, remarking
that SCP-3017’s information could not be
considered reliable, but she was unsure if
Fraisure was hiding something or simply didn’t
know anything.
During another interrogation, Fraisure’s
brother, a former classmate and two former
romantic partners were brought into the Foundation
and sedated.
In an adjacent room, Fraisure was threatened
by Doctor Kiran with a handgun and made to
answer further questions.
Every time he didn’t, the doctor threatened
to shoot one of Fraisure’s loved ones.
It was after this incident that Researcher
Rylan once again reassessed the information
given by SCP-3017.
Finally, she came to realize that there was
no evidence of Fraisure’s criminal history,
nor was there anything tying him to Groups
of Interest.
Everything that the Foundation had thought
of him was just a result of SCP-3017’s condition,
and he genuinely had none of the information
they’d been seeking.
He was only answering their questions to protect
the lives of people he cared for.
Realizing the huge ethical mistake the Foundation
had made, essentially psychologically torturing
Fraisure for information he simply didn’t
have, Researcher Rylan begged her superiors
that SCP-3017 be released.
The request was denied, and instead Rylan
was contained, believed to be a new instance
of SCP-3017-1.
With the help of Security Officer Rudolf Caridad,
who had guarded Fraisure, Rylan escaped her
own cell and the pair of them triggered a
containment alarm.
In the ensuing confusion, Rylan and Caridad
freed SCP-3017 from his incarceration, and
she and Fraisure escaped the containment facility
while Officer Caridad was captured and contained
by security personnel.
Rylan brought Fraisure to what she thought
was the safety of his family home.
But neither of them expected to see what awaited
them.
The house had been burned to the ground, with
almost all of Frasiure’s family inside.
His parents, siblings, grandmother, fiancé
and even neighbor had all perished in a fire
that had engulfed the one place in the world
that Fraisure hadn’t been held against his
will.
It is still unclear if the fire was intentionally
started by a member of the SCP Foundation
to drive SCP-3017 back to containment or had
merely been an unfortunate accident.
But notably, Doctor Kiran had been strangely
absent during SCP-3017 and Rylan’s escape
from the Foundation.
Overwhelmed with grief and despair, Fraisure
was last seen on a bridge not far from his
childhood home, and Researcher Rylan was recaptured
without resistance by Foundation personnel
near the same spot.
With SCP-3017 gone along with his cognitohazardous
effects, both her and Security Officer Caridad
were reinstated back to full employment with
the Foundation.
The Foundation then reclassified SCP-3017
as ‘neutralized’, quietly avoiding the
truth of their mistake
All records of his supposed criminal activity
and links to anomalous groups were stricken
from the record as unsubstantiated.
He had been innocent all along, just a man
who had never done anything he was accused
of and didn’t deserve to be locked away.
The SCP Foundation had tortured Fraisure,
asking him questions he didn’t have the
answers to, using the love he had for those
closest to him as a way to try and goad him
into giving the Foundation what they wanted,
and in the end, may have been responsible
for multiple innocent people being murdered.
Perhaps it was easier for them to stamp ‘neutralized’
on his file than to actually face up to what
they’d done to him.
The Foundation has spent at least a century
containing anomalies and monsters, but the
hardest monsters to contain are often the
ones that emerge within us.
And nothing better illustrates that than the
Foundation’s monstrous treatment of SCP-3017.
Now check out “SCP-5094 - Miss J's Whiz
Kidz Schoolhouse” and “SCP-507 - Reluctant
Dimension Hopper” for more SCP Foundation
stories that’ll tug at your heartstrings!